i want to jump to this uh this post here
from our good friends over at two x
chromosomes on reddit
a top post says
delete your dating apps no more women on
dating apps is the only language men
speak plus the less time you spend on
tinder the more time you can spend
protesting at the courthouse edit to all
men coming out here crying about how
you're against this of course you are
that's the point f off you know what i
love about this
the kind of guy that's going to go to
these women and be like please don't
leave the dating app but i'm i'm i'm for
abortion i'm an ally i'm an ally it's
like a good guy they're they're just
angering their own side
these these men who are doing what they
want meanwhile conservatives are like no
wait don't don't delete your dating apps
well it i mean look it just goes to show
you that like
feminists don't like male feminists
either
yeah i mean who does who doesn't no but
i think it's funny that this is the
consistent argument so we have this one
post says i deleted mine a while ago but
before this leak i was just starting to
consider trying again nope effort i'll
stick to a vibrator in my imagination
mr buzzy can't get me pregnant can't lie
about not having an sti doesn't care if
i also see mr rabbit or look at a
hitachi at the store
yo this is
there's there's
what's the right word i don't want to
say
they're crazy
but they're kind of crazy do not
understand the nuance in what's
happening here that they can they they
don't know what conservatives think
about this they've probably never even
spoken to someone who is anti-abortion
about what's really going on and why
they think it and the fact that these
women probably live in blue states
i'm just i genuinely do not understand
i don't i don't believe they actually
know what they're arguing for or against
do you think that's what they're doing
outside the supreme court justice house
is they're like deleting tinder like a
hour or nothing they're like look
kavanagh
[Laughter]
there are so many examples of
the left
circling back and coming back to
traditional like social positions
through like a back door you know i
remember a few months ago i was
listening to jordan peterson interview
this child psychologist from canada
apparently he's a he's a big wiggy won
like the nobel prize of child psychology
or whatever and he was uh he he deals
with um
designing state interventions for
children in disadvantaged homes and
studies like how this affects their
anti-social behavior their violent
behavior and stuff as they get older and
so he's describing how all these
different programs would work and he's
describing this one in the middle
he says so what we'll do is we'll have a
social worker that'll come into the
house you know of a single mother who
maybe you know doesn't have any
experience doesn't know really know like
how to handle certain things when the
kid does this or does that how they're
trying to communicate and the social
worker will be there who has this
experience who can kind of tell them
like oh this is what the kid is trying
to do and like kind of walk them through
these processes and peterson kind of
pauses for a minute he goes
well that sounds like a grandmother
and it's like then i realized everything
he had been describing were just
bureaucratic replacements for all of the
things that have been lost over the last
several decades and that was one of them
and this is kind it just sort of happens
that way well have you i want to mention
there's also an additional component to
this you're correct that the left will
end up in a roundabout way rediscovering
some form of social conservatism or
traditionalism and then at that point
the right starts defending whatever it
is the left was pushing for 50 years ago
and so historically before we just had
these like isolated nuclear families
people did tend to live with their older
relatives their older aunts or uncles or
you know parents were still living with
them helping them with the children and
now we're at a point where people are
putting their father or mother in a
nursing home when it's when it's
unnecessary just because they don't want
to deal with them and they're calling
themselves pro-family conservatives have
you seen now what the far right is
pushing
this is how it's here they want this
this this insane meme of rejecting
modernity and returning to tradition
you're going to be shocked by what i'm
going to show you in a tweet from jack
passove he says remember what they took
from you
shocking image
it's pizza hut and the pac-man machine
book it the red cups
the little dinosaurs
care bears the pizza hut lamp so jack
has been going on this what is it pizza
hut nationalism he loves pizza hut where
it's like pizza used to be great and now
it's basically i'm kidding by the way
about the far-right you know stuff the
uh oh the weird pizza claymation or
whatever it was he was telling the story
how he what he took his kids to pizza
hut because he remembered what it was
like when he was a kid and it was just
trash there was garbage everywhere it
was messy he was like what is this
and you know i'll say
he's obviously joking too
quite a bit but there is a bit of truth
into what he's saying
that
there were things that we had that were
nice that are now gone that have fallen
apart
and you mentioned it was a bureaucratic
replacement
uh darryl you're talking about a
grandmother and the state's replacement
i kind of feel like that's where we're
going where
pizza still exists but you go inside and
it's a dry shell lacking flavor lacking
anything other than you sit down here's
your pizza get out
it's the same thing happened after the
1960s you go to like 1973 is when george
lucas who was part of the new director's
movement like these rebellious dennis
hopper like all these new director types
in the late 60s easy rider all that
george lucas in 1973 makes american
graffiti which is sort of it began the
the sort of 195 the cult of 1950s
nostalgia right it's i don't know if you
guys have ever seen it it's like
as much of a stereotypical kind of 1950s
childhood movie as you can imagine and
he was open about like why he did it he
said because everything that comes out
now is depressing it sucks and we for
like the last several years every film
that's come out has just told us how bad
we are how evil the war is how etc etc
and i just didn't want any more of that
and i don't think a lot of other people
do too and it started that trend happy
days came out like a year or two later
after that and for us i think
we're kind of going through a similar
thing in the 80s and early 90s are kind
of our 1950s you know there's that 70s
show which was the late 90s right yeah
and the crazy thing is i think is it is
this true that uh yeah yeah that 70s
show was closer to the time period when
it was released than we are to the 90s
now ugh yeah because gross you know
so they're actually they're doing a
reboot i think aren't they doing a
reboot that 90s show and it's about oh
that people have nostalgia for when they
were kids and they always thought it was
better that and
it looks like yum food brands bought i
don't know if they bought pizza hut taco
bell and kfc in 90.
basically this tricon global restaurants
incorporated in 97 1997.
it came out of pepsico i it's kind of
obfuscated as to who owns what here but
i think they all got merged i just i
just got to point out that i have fond
memories of going to pizza when i was a
kid when you would get the bookit thing
you get the little wheel or whatever
with all the things you win and you go
in you get like a little pizza because
you read the books or whatever and uh
jack is obviously making a you know he's
being silly about it but there are there
are people on the left that are really
upset about jack's statements about
pizza that genuinely confuse me
it was fun going to pizza when we were
kids everything else is meant to be more
silly and a joke but talking about how
you know we the things we did back then
we don't do anymore and it kind of sucks
and
times won't stay the same forever but
it's just funny how angry they got
people they hate fun yeah
i think they're addicted to it people
have nostalgia for their childhoods all
the time obviously because your
childhood was the time before everything
got so complicated but that is also true
like on a real societal level in this
particular age you know as well like i
don't know how old all of you guys are
exactly but i'm like right at that age
where
i was you know right in that sweet spot
where i lived enough of my life about 20
years before i ever really got on the
internet i kind of knew about it and i
would you know
i'm 40. oh okay
right right at that age where you have
enough experience of the world what it
was like before everybody had
smartphones and everything and yet
you're young enough that you can just
you can pick it up and you can learn it
and you can kind of get fully integrated
and you know it has uh it's radically
changed things and i think it's made
things more complicated these kids today
will not know the joy
of hearing the phone ring and racing
your sibling full speed to try and
answer it first
or
um be watching something on television
and having to like go grab your snack
during the commercial break
actually to be honest though that is
coming back to a lot of streaming
services well there was a but i think
real quick there's a funny post where
someone said the kids today will never
know the joy of rushing to the kitchen
to grab snacks during a commercial break
and your sibling yelling it's on that's
right and then it was on tumblr someone
said they couldn't just pause it and
then someone said oh my sweet summer
chat oh that's that's hilarious but i
will say i do think there's more to it
than nostalgia so you you mentioned the
filmmakers of the 70s and i've heard it
said
that part of why star wars was so
successful and i'm not really much of a
fan but i've heard it argued part of why
it was successful is because in that era
in the 60s and 70s so much of what was
being produced was depressing but also
sort of morally ambiguous they didn't
want to have a clear-cut good guy bad
guy narrative but star wars leaned very
heavily into that and now you see a lot
of fans arguing online on twitter that
we need to have the gray jedi and this
series needs to be more about moral
ambiguity even though a huge part of
what made it successful i wanted the
fact that they were willing to draw
clear lines between what's good and bad
it was kind of a story of christ star
wars the first one luke was fighting
against the empire like jesus did and he
had magic powers like christ did and
stuff like that was a hero's journey
yeah the hero's journey is very much but
i want to make a point there's a meme
where the npc guy says who radicalized
you and then the chat guy says i'm just
a normal person from 10 years ago a
bunch of people on the left were like
see that proves you're conservative and
i'm just like bro
top surgery for 14 year old girls
there's a big difference between being
progressive and just like having no
control and my point was the eugenics
movement of the progressives in the
1900s died and was considered amoral or
immoral and unethical just because you
think just because the progressives
think they're going to win doesn't mean
their ideas are good and just because
you oppose them doesn't mean you're a
conservative you you technically i'd
argue if you're a progressive you hold
values from the early 1900s that sounds
a bit concerning artificial insemination
is eugenics i brought this up before
people messaged me were like thank you
that kind of got glazed over well unless
you mate with the very first of sexually
available person you meet then you're
kind of a eugenicist right well but i
mean
if any selectivity at all is like you're
doing a little person
but hold on look at look at women going
to sperm banks and then getting a
catalog of of of the males to choose
from
right so
i understand the argument that like a
woman will make her make her choices but
eugenics i think is better defined by
preventing people from procreating yeah
and so they're i don't know i think it's
choosing who they procreate with whether
that's no one was about good breeding
the idea was that you would have the
best possible breeding now obviously men
and women both select their mates so
when a woman goes to a sperm bank and
she's like here's the catalogue of men
it's like a guy wearing a suit it's like
iq 145 and he's a six figure salary
that's it's an extreme version of female
selection which i don't it's like okay
it's a weird modernity thing but i think
eugenics is really sour and bad when it
was like we must prevent this group from
having kids or terminate the children
that may have these traits yeah that's
the ugly head of eugenics that's for
sure
mate selection i think is normal and
fine you know a woman's going to be like
honestly dude you're like but i don't
want to have a baby with you it's like
well that's life it used to be like they
would chew the parents would choose who
the kids married for most of history i
think and relatively and and we found
that to be wrong
you know we we as
we we did away with eugenics in terms of
parents choosing who their kids would
marry and dowries and all that and then
we also decided you should stop people
from having kids which is what margaret
sanger wanted to do well like she i mean
look whatever you want to argue with
from the left they want to say she
wasn't race whatever fine but she did
want to she did argue literally and
fought very hard to stop certain people
from having kids yeah no she was
absolutely racist and she was eugenicist
but i wouldn't argue that arranged
marriage is eugenics because they were
not selecting the partner for their
child necessarily on the basis of
something like genetic fitness it could
be this is a morally virtuous person and
so i want my child to marry them or the
dad is rich yeah right it depended on
the choice of the parent they could be
like i want you to have the most
beautiful
uh wife but usually it was for money i
mean when it came to the royal families
they did not care for genetics at all so
i wouldn't call that eugenics yeah it's
about um land rights and stuff they want
the wife to have ownership like she's
going to get the the county of brussels
so i'm going to marry her to the my son
who has the kingdom of england
consolidate power all these kings in
world war one were cousins yeah
yeah so that's what i hear before we go
too far away from this pizza hut thing
yum food brands was spun up to purchase
kfc taco bell and pizza hut and the top
owners of yum food brands are vanguard
black rocket flavors state street at
four percent day
when people say that meme reject
modernity embrace tradition the one
thing i will say
i mentioned before when when you're a
tourist in key parts of the world and
you come to the famous downtown area of
some city in some far away country and
it's mcdonald's starbucks gucci hard
rock cafe you just throw up a little bit
you're just like what is this is this is
this it the world will have nothing left
to offer us yeah there's no adventure
there's no there's no diversity
you know the left talks about diversity
all day and night but i tell you when i
went to the bahamas and i was like i
guess i'll go to starbucks i'm like
that's not fun
the weird thing is when you're in
another country and they only have like
little like coffee shops where they're
making the coffee and they're burning
the bean and it doesn't taste like oh
this is all then you see a starbucks
there's like an oasis in the desert and
you're like i can get a standardized
thing that i know what it's gonna taste
like thank god and you go there and you
get a real coffee just exactly like it
always tastes nice that's the upside of
this dude standardization yeah yeah yeah
like i'm gonna i'll tell you this if i
am in
some small faraway country and their
burgers are weird and gross i still will
not go to mcdonald's not mcdonald's
starbucks
no i'll make starbucks
starbucks cold brew actually really i
think they have qualities i gotta get i
got up to that because i've been
starbucks culprit mcdonald's though i
don't like starbucks
i don't think a starbucks is fast food
really i don't ever eat their food
really so i wanted to say before we move
on for this pizza hut thing i would
think that nostalgia would be the one
thing that would be truly bipartisan
that everybody of about the same age
would really resonate with but you were
talking about the sinews that hold
people together at a very low level i
think this is one of those things the
fact that we can't even agree on some
kind of fond childhood memory is kind of
crushing to watch like that's
distressing that we don't even agree
about that what is wrong with us i
i
think i think
childhood today is being destroyed on
purpose
i think we as as millennials have a kind
of shared experience
in these cultural phenomena from when we
were little like bookit and pizza hut so
when jack pasobic posts the red cups and
the little pan pizzas many of us go i
remember that even if it was just one
time you went because your school gave
you those little things like if you if
you read enough books the teacher would
sign off and then pizza would give you a
little free pizza so you'd get it that's
a shared cultural experience now what do
we have well the shared cultural
experience is all like the weird stuff
kids are being taught in schools marvel
movies yeah i was i was just about to
bring that up i mean childhood has in
some way been been redistributed to
adults so we've extended adolescence as
far as we possibly could
i mean maybe not as far as we possibly
could we're probably pushing to extend
it even further i've been saying this
they want they they they are um
preventing adulthood that's yeah that's
what's happening whether intentional or
not puberty blockers preventing
adulthood millennials have three percent
i think fact check me on this one but
there's a meme going around like
millennials have three percent of u.s
wealth and boomers have 21 percent
it's the poorest generation in history
and uh i think it's because boomers are
living longer and i think it's because
millennials were
poorly raised yeah i think that's a huge
part of it i also think that it's the
case that when you look at the way
children are raised today i sort of
mentioned that we've redistributed
childhood right because we prolong
adolescence but on top of that it's not
as if we give to children what was
traditionally given to them so at a very
young age
eight nine ten years old a kid is handed
a smartphone which is a tool for an
adult to use but they just use it to do
unrestrained irresponsible things and
then they continue to do that until
they're 30 instead of using this tool
for something productive so it's very
strange and it's a rejection of
responsibility sadly and no culture can
function once that becomes the status
quo let's pull the audience in a way
that unashamedly promotes the show smash
the like button if you think kids should
not have cell phones there you go
i've been thinking a lot about this
because we talk about kids getting
access to the internet what age should
they get access to the internet and
what's it going to do to their brain to
have all that information blasted at me
and then i started thinking you know
what that happened to me when i was 26
years old i got on youtube and people
started hitting me with all this
information so i started looking up the
federal reserve fiat currency the bank
of international settlements the
american war machine liberal economic
order and i'm like wow we're not i i
went insane society classified would
have classified me as insane i was
completely destroyed mentally and had to
rebuild what i thought i was that's
happening to kids when they're five
seven eight and it's happening to adults
when they're 60. so this internet's
danger man it's the danger zone it's a
minefield for the mind
and we gotta treat it like that yeah and
it subverts this this
process of growing up right where like
we were talking before before the show
about this plan i have for my kids where
i'm going to have like a library and
there's going to be bookshelves full of
books so the kids grow up and they're
just used to there being books all
around and my plan is like the books at
the very bottom those are going to be
kids books get up a little higher a
little higher a little higher those are
going to be the ones where i can tell my
kid you're not ready for that yet and
then they're going to be like oh i want
that book
now that's something that happened like
with all of childhood back in the days
there were things that you were not old
enough for yet that you don't get to see
that you don't get to experience that
yet you're just not old enough you're
not at that point and it creates that
sort of yearning to mature and grow up
and now because of smartphones and just
the permissiveness of the way we raise
kids you're seven years old you can see
anything you can do anything i am
shocked and offended by what how you
described what your children will be
reading we'll be reading clearly the
only things they should be allowed to
read are harry potter and the handmaid's
teammates tell come
on what was that what was the joke
we're making a we're going to synthesize
them and do a reboot that lefties will
really pay money for it's going to be
called very handmade
that hairy hand and it was like hairy
handmade in the sorcerer's tail
something like that philosopher's tale
you're right harry i like this idea that
you're going to have books for your kids
in the future i one time my dad was was
telling i was in the bathtub i was like
six or something or seven and he started
to tell me a joke and he was like
i'll tell you when you're older and i
was like no what he's like i'll tell you
when you're older so like fifth and then
you're like a rite of passage when he
finally tells you you're like oh i've
arrived well 15 years went by and i
asked him what was that joke you were
gonna tell me he's like i don't remember
what you're talking about
so make sure they get a chance to read
the books when i was little we had cable
and the cable box man i remember this is
crazy had parental lock print to lock on
it four digit code and we whenever we
wanted to watch beeps and butt head my
mom had to be like only if i'm there we
can you know and i decide you're you're
allowed to watch it because some of
those episodes have been butted not for
little kids but some were just hilarious
yeah there's something my dad sent to me
when i was growing up which is that
and he was referring to the television
but this is the first time in human
history that people let complete
strangers into their house to teach
their children things without any kind
of filter and when you put it that way
it becomes clear just how alarming the
situation is and
yeah is this millennials doing it what
do you mean
well my dad is referring no he was
referring to his own generation and the
fact that they sit their kids in front
of the television or don't police what
they're watching they don't filter any
of it
and so
it's very very sad it's very sad and
there are so many horrible things kids
get into at an early age i mean we're
not just talking about
bad political theories or horrible
advice children end up seeing
pornography at a very early age and it
warps them dude when i was in seventh
grade
we had that one kid that every you know
male friend group has who was like the
pervert kid right and he brought a
couple of his dad's playboys to school
one time
and everybody like who found out about
was like oh my god
a couple playboys and then he got caught
by the teacher and we're like well he's
dead i mean he's clearly going to be
executed like on the playground like his
life is completely over
and it's like now today little johnny
brings a cell phone to school
and you got to explain to your
six-year-old what x y and z are that's
terrifying and instead of being like
kids shouldn't have cell phones you have
these teachers being like kids have
questions yep and we're going to answer
them and show them graphic pictures
i love it uh the the washington post
right that op-ed where it's like it's a
book about being genderqueer and kids
need these stories and it's being banned
now and then amazon's like 18 and up
only because it's got graphic depictions
of adult activities in it well and they
would not put the actual images from the
book in their publication because they
knew they were too depraved but they
were arguing that children should be
shown those images in public schools
that's how you know they're creeps yep
because they know what's in the book and
they're lying yeah it's really
remarkable actually if you go back to
the late 60s how many of the radicals
from that era
after they got done being you know fake
revolutionaries went into early uh
elementary education or like went into
the educational training you have guys
like uh
um like daniel come bendy out in france
he was a big revolutionary 68 guy out
there and afterwards he went and opened
a kindergarten and then he wrote a
memoir about it a few years after that
and he talked about she's like in the
mid 70s
talking about how you know does all of
this sexual repression is what leads to
fascism and the authoritarian
personality and everything and so if he
caught like a couple of his kids like
fondling each other or something he
would just sit there and like talk to
him while they did it make sure they
were comfortable sometimes they would
come up and touch him
this guy this guy became like a
politician in france nobody cared it got
brought up sometime in the late 90s they
tried to like use it against him and
nobody cared yes so i've i've mentioned
this on the show before but there's a
follow by the name or a disgusting
pervert by the name of alfred kinsey and
he is known as the father of the sexual
revolution he is the father of sexology
or the like the modern scientific field
of studying human sexuality and in his
published works he had data tables that
were collected by sexually abusing young
boys and this had been done to like
over 200 miners boys under the age of 15
including infants i won't explain what
the data table say on here it's really
disgusting but so much of this stuff is
completely out in the open
and the boomer generation is
comedic in a sense because i remember
growing up watching movies that the
boomer generation made about how heroic
the boomer generation was
and
there's this idea that they were these
brave revolutionaries because their
parents who had just lived through the
great depression and then fought in the
second world war came home and said you
know like we have some advice on how the
world works and you should listen to us
and they said screw you mom and dad i'm
gonna have one night stands and listen
to rock and roll and this is considered
this really brave and important
revolution it was just a bunch of
spoiled children it was just a bunch of
spoiled children completely tarnishing
and squandering their inheritance thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there
you